as we look for the perfect gifts for our
loved ones the choices can be
overwhelming but one trend is helping to
simplify things by changing the gift
itself yeah we spoke with someone who
shared how you can still gift the magic
without the Box this holiday season
travel host and expert Davey Sutton says
gifting travel is a great alternative to
a traditional present so I'm at
beautiful Castaway Key which is Disney's
Private Island exclusively for Disney
Cruise Line guests and I'm aboard the
Disney wish which is the newest ship of
the cruise line collection and when
you're on board you get access to all of
our Disney faves like you could turn the
corner and run into a princess Sutton
says using hobbies and themes are great
starting points when planning and
detailed the options available on board
like right now it's all about the
holiday magic but there's other uh sales
that like if you have friends who are
superhero fans and fans of the Marvel
there's a Marvel day at Sea and brand
new for 2023 there's Pixar dancing which
you can have encounters with characters
from your favorite Pixar movies like
Monsters Inc and Toy Story contact your
travel agent or visit disneycruise.com